The joe rogan experience.
As long as you keep chucking that,
hey over the side,
keep it coming,
keep dead.
Hey,
come on baby.
Yeah,
good to go.
When we have connections with certain animals,
elephants are a big one,
you know?
Um,
lions are a big one.
Giraffes for whatever reason are a big one.
Even zebras,
people like,
why are you shooting at Zebra?
Too much like a horse?
Yeah,
like we have these,
but if it's like an antelope that you eat,
like all that kind of makes sense.
Like we have these kind of makes sense animals and again,
wart hogs.
Nobody gives a fuck about warthogs.
There's no one out there trying to save the Warhawk.
People don't even know how many there are.
They don't care and care less like people worried about lions and no one is out
there wondering how many ward hogs are,
are left in Africa.
I see it all the time.
It's like people will comment,
not hunters,
obviously,
but they'll be like on my page and say,
well,
oh,
I don't have a problem if you killed deer and elk,
but there's no reason to kill a bear.
Right.
What are you talking about?
Have you ever had bear sausage?
Yeah.
Well,
if you've had beer saw and you,
you probably haven't,
but if you,
if you have,
it's Goddamn good.
And why is it any different?
It's the same.
Why is it any different?
Yeah,
it's not.
so it's just what they're,
it's just what they're ingrained to feel about an animal,
I think.
Well they,
they seem to dog like thanks.
Yeah.
That's a thing.
That's the thing with people that bears just seem dog like,
oh,
they're portrayed as being nice if people have them for pets too.
Like there's a lot of people that have bears pets like a hot Russian people am
in on Instagram.
Do you have lunch?
Fine.
Them,
this is one motherfucker as a giant grizzly bear that he cuddles with.
People keep sending me videos of this guy.
I'm like,
one day,
I know I say this video is going to get dark.
God.
Yeah.
Look at this guy.
It's got a sweet bear.
It's just chilling with this bird,
this bird month moon.
And we hung out
my girlfriend and her rubbers back,
but one day my baby.
Yeah.
It looks like it looks like a cool bear.
It's dope bear.
Look,
they're fucking awesome animals,
man.
I love all of them.
Yeah.
But here's the deal.
If you had a thousand of those living in your neighborhood,
you'd have to thin the herd.
Yeah.
You just have to,
and the reality of all this stuff is super complex and I just do not think you
get an understanding of it from,
you know,
in front of your laptop in Vancouver.
You just,
you don't know for sure.
Okay.